RIGHT ON CUE, DAVID PASTRNAK
LIGHTS THEERRANT PASS LEADS TO T
OPPORTUNITY.
BRIAN:GOES TO THE BACKHAND.
TIAN
USING HIS SPEEDUSING , ABLE TO E
DOWN LOW, TRIED TO STOP ONE GOAE
BRUINS, AND THE PASTRNAK HAS GOT
PASTRNAK.
TERRIFIC FEED.
A.J.: YOU LOOK AT THESE TWO SEN.
BOB:GLOVE SAVE MADE BYDS THE NES
KICKED OUT OF TH
OF SAVES WITH 13:55 TO GO IN TH.
THE FLYERS ARE ON THE BOARD.
THEY HAVE CUT THEHE SCREEN, THE.
AND THEN THE REDIRECT.
SAVE MADE
GOALTENDERS.
ANYTIME THAT OPEN BEHIND THE NET
HELPS TO LOCATE WHERE THE SHOT
IS COMING FROM BUT YOUABEE, THAS
STOPPED BY TUUKKA FARABEE COMES
IN.
TRIES TO GO.
BRIAN: THIS IS A TERRIFICALLY
SKILLED PLAY HEREKAWAY A TOWARDK
LOOKING FOR THE HAT TRICK AND
LOOKED LIKE CART
PASTERNAK
INHINK
ANYTHING SHOULD HAVE BEEN CALLED
THERE. SAVE.
OFHIS PERIOD.
STUFFING ONE IS DEBRUISE.
AND IT'S LOOSE UNDER
THOSE GOAL TENDERS, HE'S CALM IN
ON HART.
SAVE
AND HE IS BATTLING FOR HIS TEAM
GIVING T GOAL MOUNT.
HIM AND MAKING SURE THERE'S NO
CHANCE FOR THAT SECOND LOOK.BOB.
OH, RINGING ONE OFF THE
BUT IT STARTED WITH THE PATIENC!
SHOT OFF THE END BOARD AND
ATKINSON STOPPED BY RASK.
THE REBOUND BY.
BOB: RIEMSDYK.